oh
feels good to just hit record
not care
welcome to a new kind of video all right
so i wanted to make like a hazel devlog
and
uh like i've always struggled with the
idea of making devlogs because and i
think a lot of youtubers probably face
this because when you're making content
for youtube it's not necessarily
doesn't necessarily represent well
what it's like to actually
you know engineer software whether it be
like a game engine or if you're actually
working on like a video game and so
you're making like
a devlog for your video game
like it's it's hard to try and base
content around it especially when
the areas that you're working on are
seemingly boring and like i mean i have
the unders i have this idea that nothing
like you can make something interesting
no matter what it is doesn't matter how
boring or mundane
a task you're working on is like you can
find a way to make it interesting
and that is what this video is this
video is an attempt to kind of provide
you with some content and some update as
to what's going on
with hazel
uh even though there's not much going on
at least from my side at the moment and
the stuff that is going on is more or
less like
kind of behind the scenes like software
engineering practices and processes and
stuff like that so ever since probably
like october last year which was like
optimization october i've had this kind
of uh
thing that i've wanted to do which has
ultimately been to like
you know just make hazel higher quality
um because
the thing is when you kind of have a
base set of features which we do like
we've made several games
using hazel now right like we made we
made that fragile game within like 12
hours tim and i
then peter tim and i
made forest for ludum dare 50. right and
and tim made this kind of script
invaders game as well which was like a
space invaders clone but with like you
know a lot more stuff going on and then
i also made like the rocket game in like
an hour and a half so we we technically
have
four games well there's other projects
as well behind the scenes but there's
four like more or less playable games
that we've made using hazel in like the
last six months or so
and like this is just a fantastic
opportunity i think to go back over what
we've got and refine it because the
problem is that as as you kind of get
further along
anything that you're developing you can
just keep adding features and
clunking everything together but the
further the further down you get you
know down the track the the harder it
becomes to be like hang on wait a minute
is what we've got does it work well
is it well optimized you know will it
will it kind of perform across a range
of hardware and runtime devices
right or is it like really kind of like
specific and narrow
in the way that it works but it's still
kind of good enough do we keep jamming
features in
or do we kind of slow down and find what
we've got to make sure that it's as
solid as possible before we move on and
like that ladder approach there like i'm
really a big a big fan of that
because it's just it's so first of all
it's really satisfying to just make
something that's actually good
right but then also if you build a
strong foundation
then when you start adding more stuff
onto it the foundation's going to
support the stuff better if you just
keep piling on
new features on new features without
going back and making sure everything is
really good then eventually you're going
to come to the point where stuff just
doesn't work and it's going to be a huge
pain to go over everything and fix it
and so that's why like i've kind of been
focusing a little bit more on
thinking about you know how we can maybe
take hazel
and make it a high quality product so
there's been like a few changes to the
actual way that we do things in the
hazel team now by the way for all of you
watching on youtube like i don't know
how much you
care about this stuff like it's
difficult for me to gauge because i've
been in this hazel world for a while and
so that's why i like these devlogs
they're ultimately supposed to be
um something that hopefully shows you
you know what it's like to actually work
on like a a decently sized project with
a team
i think that's useful content to to
people who want to also either build
their own game engines or just you know
become potentially better engineers
but also it should be some somewhat
entertaining i hope so
you know if you guys just let me know in
the comments what you think of these
videos and what you would like to see
more in devlogs
uh that would be very helpful because
i've like literally there hasn't been a
devlog since probably last year because
i haven't really
been able to
pinpoint how to make one which seems
weird because i've made so many in the
past but
i don't know what i'm doing so
i've been i've been i've gotten too deep
into the code into like actual
engineering that
coming back and making videos and
devlogs on hazel seems a bit weird which
is why you're getting this weird video
here which anyway whatever so hazel's
users are pretty much all patrons
patreon.com
if you don't know is where you support
like hazel and what we're doing and all
that and then you get access to like all
the source code so if you if we if we
take a look at like the the users that
we have there obviously the people
downloading the engine you know most
people are going to hit the master
branch because that's the default branch
on the on like the git lab repository so
the idea obviously is that we want that
to be as good as possible
now currently master has been
uh basically something that we
treat as a development branch so when
obviously like in a small project when
you kind of begin you know you you might
break off to different branches as you
add features or fix
certain issues right but then eventually
you merge that back into master and then
you know masters like your main branch
and then you kind of maybe do a lot of
work there as well because you know it's
a small enough project where it doesn't
matter too much but as the project goes
and grows in size
you kind of want to uh
you know maybe
like you really need to pay a little bit
more attention to the quality of your
main branch because
the complexity of the software increases
to the point where it might not be
trivial to fix issues but also like it
becomes way way harder
to test the everything
right like if you have an engine with
five features then it's just easy to run
through all that you know maybe try and
open a bunch of different scenes hit
play uh does it work yes uh do i hear
audio yes move on done you know but
obviously like
you know imagine something the size of
unity or unreal
imagine if you had something that big
how are you possibly going to test every
feature like it's pretty much impossible
right and then obviously when you look
at teams like like those they have a lot
of they'll have a lot of infrastructure
in place for things like that not just
dedicated qa teams that will actually
run through
everything right but then there's
probably like a lot of automation going
on
to make sure that like certain tasks
that can be automated obviously
automatically by a computer
that can be done because it becomes
really really taxing and expensive to
have a human
run over every possible action in unity
right like that's just not gonna fly and
so that's why like you know unit testing
is not something that is
that i believe is
is fully appropriate for a game engine
uh it's it's it's definitely useful for
some things you know like i'm thinking
of like maybe like i don't know the math
library or something right like
obviously there are a lot of things that
you can unit test and you can easily
feed in a bunch of inputs have a bunch
of expected outputs
you know try and boil it down to one
unit of work and then maybe you've got a
way to actually properly test something
but in a lot of cases you know if i want
to for example load a 3d model and
render it and does that work and then
hit play and is the physics responsive
and you know what how long does that
take and all of that stuff
that's clearly like something that
you can't really unit test so
it becomes a little bit more of a
creative process where you might design
some kind of you know automation code
that will for example try and load a 3d
model hit play and then see first of all
are there any errors does it crash and
does it run
you know and also possibly even capture
maybe frames of certain scenes and
compare them you know just like an image
diff really compare them to like
the previous version like because we
probably wouldn't expect
graphics to change right
and that's obviously you know if you can
load a 3d model and display it and the
pixels match up with like what it was
like in the previous version then
you can probably say that that does in
fact work so my point with all of this
is just to say that as the project grows
you clearly like also have to like
grow in terms of
how you
develop the project and how you try and
maintain quality
for that project and so for hazel i
think that's probably long overdue i
mean as soon as we had an engine that
was capable of making anything really
i think it was pretty much time to do
this and that is to kind of uh more or
less move to like releases
so
what i've done is i've basically like
said that the master branch is now
completely locked no one can actually
commit to that except for me
and
uh you know so the entire team basically
works off of this dev branch
and the dev branch is called dev and
it's basically like master
you know in the sense that like it's a
it's like the central hub for everyone
on the team to like merge their
their features into right so if you're
working on like animation or physics or
scripting or like audio or whatever and
you've just introduced some new things
in your like audio branch and you want
to merge it in you merge it into dev now
instead of merging it into master
and then what happens is master is like
the release branch so
in other words like master is the branch
that is uh supposed to represent a
release which means that it doesn't get
updates too frequently so every now and
then you know we'll merge something into
master we'll merge dev into master
but then like
that's not going to be that often and
when that happens
before it really gets published into
master it's getting very bright here
before it gets published into master
it will be like
we'll test it you know we'll qa kind of
test it make sure that everything works
uh you know we'll do a proper testing
pass over it instead of just kind of
merging it in and being like does it
compile does it run
that's it
which is kind of like what's been
happening
at the moment like it's everyone just
kind of merges into master
and then like there's no real guarantee
of quality and then you know like
if i take a break from hazel and then i
come back to it after a while
you know because i'm working on like the
ray tracing series or the game engine
series or whatever and then i'm like oh
this doesn't work anymore
you know it becomes a little bit
annoying because there's no real
guarantee that that something works and
i think that like for people who
obviously who
like support the project and our patrons
and all of that like
there should be i think at this point
some expectation of quality
when it comes to hazel and so that's
kind of what what we're doing um
at the moment we're moving more towards
like a release model which is very
exciting because like
you know when it comes down to it
um i i do want to eventually release
hazel as like a
kind of an engine just like as like a
binary release that people can download
and play around with even if you don't
like pledge money to the project
um and obviously like you know the way
that we run it at the moment like if
it's it's on patreon and
you know thanks to the supporters on
patreon like we're able to like hire
people like tim and peter you know to
work on the project and get paid for it
you know um i can dedicate obviously a
lot of my time working on hazel as well
so like the supporters are extremely
important to the project like it
wouldn't be it wouldn't be at the state
that it's in
if it wasn't for those people you know
on patreon supporting us so
that has to remain to some degree
otherwise the project will just fall
apart but i do want to eventually
release like hazel for free as like a
binary release so that people can
actually play around with it maybe make
something with it um i think that would
be really cool to kind of do in the
future so
this is exciting because it's kind of
like a step in that direction like we're
actually saying now that you know
we're introducing the concept of
releases and we're introducing the
concept of like you know we have like a
version of hazel that has a set of
features those features are tested
and those features
work well
you know so
yay
exciting stuff um yeah like
and as i mentioned there's a bunch of
like automation stuff
that goes into this as well like i want
to set up like a laptop i have like this
old laptop
from like five years ago or something i
want to set that up in the office
as like some sort of
uh continuous integration machine and
maybe integrate that with gitlab ci so
that we can actually
you know for every commit well
especially into master but probably the
dev branch as well every commit that
comes in you know gets built in every
configuration debug release disk
um you know
we have some kind of automation that
will launch like hazelnut and maybe the
hazel run time
you know after it compiles successfully
um
to make sure that like we can load maybe
all of the scenes that come shipped kind
of with the engine in the sandbox
project
you know making sure that like we can
run everything without crashing just
like some base level
ci i guess this is some base level
testing to make sure that that stuff
does in fact work i think that would be
good so i might show that in like the
next devlog or something this has been
kind of a
discussion dev vlog i don't know like
this has been a very spontaneous video
like i kind of just set up the camera
here and i thought i would just talk to
it for fun and see what happens
um but i guess this is probably like a a
decently interesting video so
let me know what you guys thought of
this devlog um it's kind of more more
like a it reminds me of something that i
would have done back in the day where i
just would have done like a little vlog
type type deal and talk to the camera
for a while about stuff so yeah anyway
let me know what you guys think of these
sorts of videos and if you want to see
more of this kind of
chill style vlog content i don't know
maybe i'll put more of this stuff up
onto the channel on plug channel
um because that channel is kind of more
for for this stuff i guess uh but yeah
we'll see how this video i guess goes
here and if you guys want to see more
just let me know in the comment section
below because it has been a while since
the last devlog like there are a lot of
features they're mostly minor stuff
but i guess they're kind of interesting
obviously there's been a lot of work
that's gone into hazel a lot of it as i
mentioned has been kind of going back
and and refining the quality of certain
areas and systems in the engine but
there's also been like a bunch of stuff
that um
is new and is new right and and i'm kind
of certainly working on like the
distribution side of things when i have
the chance which is more or less making
sure that we can package assets
appropriately and ship them in like a
runtime format
um and then yeah as i mentioned we do
have a bunch of features so i might run
through some of those like in the next
devlog and we'll also potentially talk
about like setting up that ci thing but
yeah that's kind of my plan so
i hope you enjoyed i'll see you all
later goodbye